fundamentally disagree that Pearl said
because he's a pretty reasonable girl
what did you disagree with oh man you're
going to text my memory here
um I think that the wholesale idea of
like women have it easier and every
single thing or there are like no
cultural roadblocks preventing women
from doing anything I think it's like a
really crude analysis of where we're at
socially that's what I would say so
you're saying that she's discounting how
yeah I think that there are issues that
women face in a lot of different areas
when it comes to like rising in terms of
success or in being included in certain
languages okay so this is a very
interesting Dynamic that you guys have
going right now you're the man saying
that like defending women and she's the
woman
[ __ ] on women essentially is that
the dynamic I'm understanding so she's
basically saying this is what it is like
to be a woman
I would say there's no barriers to entry
today
I don't think Pearl believes there's no
issues that women face that's different
right no that's literally what she just
said there's no barriers it's easier for
women than men no the difference between
there's no barriers to entry and there's
no issues that a woman can face you
wouldn't say there's no issues a woman
can face is there I mean there are
issues that women face but I would say
overall it's easier for women than men
yeah
easier in what regard what are we
talking about here I mean I just think
being a man versus being a woman you're
saying it's easier to be I mean okay
I'll give you an example so I worked a
sales job right and when I worked in
that sales job it was at a big like
corporate company and I feel like I got
special treatment because I was a woman
and most of the guys and I was the only
girl in the office and most of the guys
would agree because like people were
more willing to help you when you're a
young woman I in my experience
so I can't speak to your personal
experience but so this is something that
I hear a lot when women are succeeding
in certain types of environments they do
get special treatment but all of those
women's careers have a time limit on
them which is until a manager or boss
tries to [ __ ] them and when they say no
they're basically [ __ ] in that job
this is a story that I hear Time and
Time and Time and Time and Time Again do
you think this happens ever quite often
the boss loses his job no absolutely
absolutely you don't hear the story that
goes public like that this happens to
I've heard this from almost every single
woman working in entertainment and
working at any industry peripheral to
this that if you are a moderately
attractive woman working yeah like
you're working you might be succeeding
but you never know if you're actually
succeeding based on the merits of your
work or because somebody wants to [ __ ]
you and when somebody tries to [ __ ] you
if you shut them down you're [ __ ]
because whoever's above you hates you
now and they're never gonna [ __ ]
promote you or work with you anymore and
then you slowly basically get ghosted
out of whatever job you're working
a million dollars do what or you go to
HR and the dude gets fired and then you
get settlement that just doesn't happen
most of the time I
I just delusional world where like every
guy is getting false sex claims every
creepy boss or pervert is getting fired
everyone yeah this happens like 1.001 of
the time like it's very very rare that
somebody actually gets caught or called
out on this because usually when these
guys are propositioning you you don't
even they're not really even being 100
forward with it right so you're not
going to get them on anything right
actually eight percent of the US
population claims they've been falsely
accused that's okay but with that poll
was that poll falsely accused to the
police or was that poll like my friend
told another friend that somebody like
raped me it was probably the louder it
was absolutely the latter because eight
percent of false rape allegations to the
police everybody will be talking about
it I know that's not true yeah I agree
with you on the false rate accusations
you're as likely to get convicted as you
are to get struck by lightning I've read
that stat huh so again you disagree with
pearl on the fundamental situation that
women have it easier than that here's my
perspective are you counter-back
pushback
I always ask this question I said who
has it harder out there men or women and
constantly I hear well men have it
harder bro we gotta [ __ ] dig the
ditches we gotta have the tough jobs or
the one that got to pay the bills men
have it harder and I said a little food
for thought here's why I think women
have it harder in today's society I want
to open up to you guys as a man
I'm all about clarity as a man it might
be hard to make money to be fit to learn
game to pick up chicks to be successful
it might be hard but at least you know
the pattern for Success at least there's
a blueprint here's what you need to do
put a [ __ ] nice suit on or some nice
sweatpants for Destiny look good get
your ass out there meet people succeed
make money the world's your oyster now
what's your advice to women
is it get out there get a career get a
job kill it maybe or is it be a good
wife be submissive don't be a [ __ ]
[ __ ] like don't go on only fans be a
good housewife stay in the kitchen be a
traditional woman which one is it
because it's totally polarizing opposite
advice for women so again I'm all about
Clarity it's very me easy for me to look
in the camera talk to you guys out there
and be like you're too fat you're too
lazy stop smoking weed stop watching
porn get your ass out there work do your
thing you'll find success done blueprint
as a woman what do you say to a woman go
get a job go to college be a boss babe
now you're single and lonely at 40. hey
don't don't get a job you know get your
get yourself a husband figure like let
your like let the man lead you be the
follower it's like now you're divorced
at 40 because you're in a sexist
marriage so it is very hard for a woman
so my argument is it's actually a lot
harder for a woman to decide what to do
what's your argument to that Pearl yeah
I mean it depends what
what
I think you make different choices based
on the outcome you want
okay so how do you know but like this
goes back to my college thing is how do
you know what your outcome you want when
you're 16 17 18 years old very hard to
do yeah yeah I mean that's that's
definitely a challenge that women have I
agree with you yeah what are your
thoughts I I don't like the saying like
one is harder or one is easier I think
that women have very unique challenges
they face I think men have unique
challenges they face um I don't know if
I would ever say that one is harder or
one is easier like if you are a pretty
woman you can get your feet in the door
in a lot of different ways that men
can't but then you get sexually harassed
but yeah but then there's the trade-off
is that everybody's trying to [ __ ] you
right that's a pro everybody's trying to
[ __ ] you but it's also a big con that
everybody's trying to [ __ ] you I think
of all like the archetypes of women that
I've met in my life I feel like really
hard working
but very pretty women have it probably
the worst because they're constantly
gaslighting themselves into having no
idea if they're actually achieving or
you know being successful or if
everybody's just like basically giving
them handouts because they want to [ __ ]
them eventually and like living in that
kind of like Duality is a very very
confusing place to be like as a man like
if I'm getting credit for something as
much as I like to believe it it's not
because some woman wants to [ __ ] me who
knows because I'm actually succeeding
yeah
the only reason I have me on the show is
because we're all trying to [ __ ] you but
for like a woman yeah you legitimately
have no [ __ ] idea like am I
performing well my boss give me a lot of
compliments my co-workers seem to like
me am I getting a leg up everywhere
because you do get a lot of help if
you're one if you're a woman in computer
science you're the only woman in the
class well at least for white women
you're getting a lot of [ __ ] help in
that class compared to anybody else let
me recap what you just said bro because
that's very powerful if you're if you're
a hard-working working attractive woman
then what you never know like are you
successful on your own merits or is
everybody around you just gaslighting
you into thinking that while they're
trying to [ __ ] you I think a woman would
know
oh well you would know like oh I I
really put in work like I achieved this
recognition because this work is it's
phenomenal versus like you can tell by
how they address you how they speak with
you because I do agree with you you're
in a workplace and there are men who
want that intention but as a woman you
can approach approach that situation
knowing that that's their intention so I
think as a woman like you can determine
like am I getting this credible uh am I
getting credit based on my work or my
granite getting credit based on my looks
like as a woman who is attractive like
you can tell like you can tell when a
man's flirting with you you can tell
when a man wants something from you you
can see that I think I I would agree
with you for the most part but I think
there's two things one I think every
attractive woman goes through a point in
her life where she realizes like [ __ ] a
lot of this has come from my looks I
think that comes a little bit later than
at least as a guy we would assume
um and then two I think that it gets
really hard around like edge cases where
you're like trailblazing right if you're
like an sales department and you've got
like [ __ ] numbers right and you can
see like obviously I'm outperforming
that's fine but if you're working in
like entertainment or if you can reach
out to like CEOs of companies they're
calling you back or if you're getting
like invited a podcast or whatever
there's always this like whatever and I
think a lot of guys are really good at
disguising their intentions where a guy
can treat you in the most respectful
manner possible until you're traveling
to some [ __ ] convention in the same
place somewhere and he tries to get your
drunk and rape you I think that it's
really really difficult sometimes to
feel out like the fuzzy edge cases if
there's guys that are like blatantly
stuck up you can tell but I think it's
just a weird thing for a woman to always
have that in the back of her head voice
for guys we never there's not a time in
our life for a really successful guy
that you never know if the girl's into
him for him or his money very good point
that is true very good point go deeper I
think it's better for a woman for a guy
yeah if you're the more successful you
are you're like does she love me for me
or the fact that I make a million
dollars a year that's something that is
a very good point you know who's even
better than disguising their intentions
than men women are women are much better
playing the game
to get ahead too yeah of course A lot of
times like these girls will flirt with
their bosses and then play victim later
yeah well they fundamentally agree on
that but Alex I want to kind of stay
where you were that you're saying all
right cool we're [ __ ] on guys and
being kind of shady or whatever
it could be just so shady when they're
messing with a successful guy especially
in Miami and a lot of these rich guys
they get completely screwed they are
like [ __ ] they get trained for all their
money because they [ __ ] with the wrong
girl and then she took pretty much
everything what have you seen have you
seen I've seen I've had countless
clients I've had that happen to them
yeah they got married early then they
you know their business became
successful or they got married when
their business was already successful to
the wrong kind of girl right so
screening is important for both genders
I don't think it's only something that
women have to screen with the people in
the world like men also have to screen
real quick that could be possible I
would be curious what type of guy it is
maybe because I might be this might be
my bubble because of the industry that I
work in but it's very easy for me to
tell immediately how a girl feels about
me she's like fake or not because like
you either know everything that I'm
involved in or not like if a girl came
up to me and she wanted to have like an
in-depth conversation about like [ __ ]
fiscal policy to try to fake me out for
my money I mean I'll pay her off like
good job
you don't think a woman can tell when a
guy's trying to [ __ ] them most women can
tell that too no I think women can tell
but I'm just saying that like if a woman
is trying to just like get in good with
me because she thinks I've got money
like I think I'm gonna be able to weed
that out really funny dress here's what
I want to address if you're that dude
and you're having success and you're
doing things in your life and you're
single and you're out there what type of
question should you ask these women to
vet them because I totally agree with
you there's women out there that see a
dollar sign on a guy and they're like
sugar daddy just walked in like there's
a video of a girl that she's like here's
the best place to find a sugar daddy you
don't go to clubs you don't go to strip
clubs you go to the nice restaurants
because there they are they're all
together I call it the sugar daddy
Watering Hole I've seen this girl do
this video and she's like they're all at
the nicest restaurants in Miami or New
York Early whatever and they're all
eating together doing their thing so you
as a dating coach what types of
questions should a man ask women up
front to kind of vet what the woman is
looking for I think it's less about
questions and more about not leading
with your money so I like the Dave
Chappelle joke where he says like when I
have a date I drive up in a dumpster
truck and then when the girl's like oh I
don't want to date a dumpster job he's
like I'm Dave Chappelle [ __ ] so I kind
of like that like whole idea that you're
not taking the girl to a fancy
restaurant you're not leading with your
money uh you're not like showing off
your car you're keeping all that hidden
until you get to know her and if she
legitimately [ __ ] with you
without seeing all your wealth and it's
like a nice cherry on the top so that
would that's what I would recommend I
feel like definitely very idealistic hey
I just happened to be Dave Chappelle
answer but that's not the reality
because we live in Miami you know what
it's like you kind of got to give a
little bit of crumbs a little bit
and then you can kind of reveal but okay
but even to get the date with the girl
like if you're some dude at the bar
you're gonna have to say something to be
like well I do this for work and I do
this like I'm not saying you have to
drive up in your Lamborghini and take
her to home to your Mansion but you have
to say like well yeah I'm actually like
I own this bar or like yeah my friends
own this bar or yeah I'm an attorney or
whatever you're gonna have to give them
some sort of game but you do have to
have a conversation ask them questions
so I fully agree don't just let you know
let the money do the talking for you but
you do have to ask some questions what
questions would you actually ask them I
don't think there's a specific question
I would ask the girl I think I would
just literally not do any of the stuff
you're saying I would not if I was the
owner of the bar if I was just trying to
get laid yeah sure I would use that to
my advantage but if I was looking for a
relationship I would leave all that part
out I would not stress the fact that you
know I'm friends with the owner I would
leave all that out I think you can also
just have a good game and make the girl
laugh and build a lot of sexual tension
and lead with that instead of leading
with possessions of money I think I had
to actually just answered my own
question and I think that the answer is
you need to ask them questions yeah I
don't think there's a specific question
I think I just answered what I was
trying to ask you
if you're I see this problem whether
it's in business or whether it's in
dating guys just want to talk about
themselves
and it's like selling isn't telling
selling is asking okay so hey what are
you doing here who you're here with what
are you guys looking to do tonight and
if you're getting like you'll get these
answers we're just trying to find a dude
with a yacht I've
if I had a [ __ ] dollar for every time
a girl said that I'd be [ __ ]
gazillionaire we're just trying to find
a yacht to party on it's like cool good
luck with that yacht if they're like hey
yeah I'm just visiting like my grandma
and I'm in town it's like cool Family
Values got it boom boom asking questions
is the best thing you could do yes you
could I think you're saying there's no
specific questions which I I think I
changed my mind about actually you could
ask what type of guys does she usually
date you could ask well there we go baby
you are changing your mind there's
questions you've changed my mind yeah
you could ask that yeah so what
questions you would you ask I would ask
about her like once we're already
talking or vibing I would ask about her
last relationship I'd be like oh yeah so
what kind of guys do you are usually
into yeah I'll start off with that she
would tell me like oh cool so do you are
you with a typical Miami sugar baby and
then see how she responds to that she'd
be like no you know my last guy was
broke okay that's something where she's
like um well I do like Millionaires and
that's a different story yeah I think
the question that we asked yesterday is
actually probably one of the first
questions you should ask a girl how's
your relationship with your dad yeah I
think I I don't think you're gonna ask
that on a first date don't get me wrong
I mean I don't know the first time
you're not gonna go up to a girl in a
bar and be like hey how do you doing can
I buy a drink how do you get along with
your dad but I think that is a very
important question to ask a girl like I
don't think it's a very weird situation
I don't think it's a coincidence that
Pearl is the girl she is and she has an
amazing relationship with her father I
think that is the reason that is the pro
the girl that she is would you agree or
disagree no I agree
um I look up give a shout out to your
dad no I look up to my dad a lot like a
lot of um
I don't know I feel like a lot of the
reasons like I do things that I do is
like I was always trying to like make my
dad proud I don't know which is kind of
lame I know but I don't know sorry your
dad is really sorry okay what like dude
I'm gonna give you some credit here
senior girl she's cute you get girls
okay despite the pajamas you get girls
it's because of the pajamas it's because
band Tick Tock and we are demonetized on
a daily basis on this platform if you
want to help please consider sending a
super thanks below every donation helps
and it helps make what we do possible